AJ Hoffman, how you doing, man?
>> Yeah, I'm all good, man. How are you?
>> I'm [snorts] good. I'm good. I'm good.
Blessed.
>> Okay. So, I just listened to what you uh
the conversation that you had with uh I
forgot what his name was. So, I'm just
wondering like um the point that he
made, why are you dismissing it as
though he doesn't know what he's talking
about? Obviously, he's way younger than
you, so it's very easy to overpower him.
But the logic in his answer, why why are
you dismissing it? And what was wrong
with it? So then everybody who's
listening can hear it.
>> What was the logic in his answer?
>> So, so what he said was that in the
Quran when it's referring to the
previous books is confirming the
previous books are correct. So what is
with you Jews, Christians, the books
that were provided for you, we're
confirming this. The Quran confirms
this. So that's the that's what his
point was.
>> Is that what he said?
>> Oh, that's how I understood it.
>> He said he said that they don't have the
scriptures with them. They only have
them in name as in they it's been
revealed to them before and so it's
connected to them. They don't actually
have the actual scriptures. That's what
his point was. You agree with that?
>> No. No. I uh from my understanding when
I was listening I I I didn't take that
from what he said was he's saying the
Quran is mentioned that he's saying the
Quran is talking about them in name.
He's not saying that there was no uh
books at that time.
>> But that's what he said though. He said
they didn't have them at that time. They
didn't have the true pure version of
them at that time. They only had them in
name.
>> Okay. Okay. So, I agree. I agree that
they didn't have the pure versions at
that time.
>> Okay, I got you. So, I'll I'll I'll I'll
repeat now
>> the verse to you. 241. It says,
>> "Believe in what I have revealed,
confirming that which is with you." What
was with them?
>> So, as a Christian and as a Jew, what is
with you is your books.
>> Thank you. So, they had books with them.
And the books that they had with them,
which are the Torah and Gospel, Psalms,
writings of the prophets, right?
>> These books that the that the Jews and
Christians had with them, the Quran
attested that they were true, right?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. That that's that's all. So yeah.
So in Muhammad's time, they had true the
books they had were true. They were not
false and corrupted.
>> No, no, you're you're you're correlating
mistakenly. So the point that you made
is correct. So the Quran confirms that
the books that were revealed in the past
at the original time, they were the
correct books. They were from God. So
the second point that you're making is
the books that were with them are the
ones that are true. So you're trying to
confirm. But by the way, confirmation
doesn't mean dependence cuz you made a
previous point saying that this is why
the Quran is dependent on on the Bible.
So
>> we could get we could get to the
dependence next. That that'll be a fun
train, but depends on how this goes. If
if this goes well, if we if we can get
past phase one,
>> give me a second. Give me a second.
>> Just cover your thoughts. Cover your
thoughts. It's all good.
>> Well, I got my thoughts together. I just
want to make sure that my words
>> You have good tactics.
>> Thank you. I'm a master, so I hear.
>> Yes.
>> All right. If we can get past phase one
of this simple acknowledging of what the
text says, then we will be able to
progress further in the conversation.
But usually the problem that I usually
have with most Muslims that I talk to is
that we can't get past phase one because
you guys can't believe or be honest with
what your text says when we're reading
it. You guys will say the opposite of
what the text says. So hopefully you're
gonna be different. Hopefully you are
going to be honest with what your text
says and you're not going to play games
with me. I'm putting my hope in you.
Okay. All right. So
>> you're hoping to get what you want to
hear.
>> All I want to hear is the truth. That's
all. All I want to hear the truth.
>> The verse says,
"Believe in what I have revealed." What
has been revealed? So everything that
God's revealed, go on, carry on.
>> No, specifically he's talking about he's
talking about the Quran. He's adjuring
the Jews to believe in the Quran.
>> Yep.
>> Believe in what I have revealed.
Confirming that which is with you.
>> Yep.
>> And we already agreed that what is with
them is are their books. Right.
>> Okay.
>> So they had their scriptures with them.
They had possession. They had their
books with them in their possession. Can
we agree?
>> Yep. Yep.
>> All right. And so the Quran says that
the books you have with you, the books
in your possession, the Quran is
confirming those.
>> Meaning it's attesting to the truth of
those books you have, not that you had
in the past that you have now. Can we
agree?
>> Okay. So the Quran says like [snorts]
you just mentioned, so if you are
willing to listen, be a bit open-minded
and then you can try to understand my
point. So that's what it says. That does
it confirms what it says.
>> All right. So that's what it says.
>> That's all I ask if we that we can agree
with what it says.
>> Yeah. Yeah. 100%. We will never disagree
with what the Quran says. As a Muslim,
obviously logically you have to reason
from my Yeah. Yeah. So [snorts] okay. So
the Quran is saying to Christians and
Jews that this book which I'm revealing
confirms what is with you. So if I'm so
just listen to my point so hopefully you
understand. So if I'm talking to
Christians and Jews I'm like this is the
holy Quran. The opposite of me saying
that this confirms what is with you is
saying that this goes against your
books. So the point here is being made
is that this is not an enemy to your
books. This confirms the message of your
books. So it's not saying that your
books are 100% true that you have with
you. Why is there need for a revelation?
So, are you going to listen or or are
you just going to cry? So, give me a
logical point why you don't understand.
Is it getting hot?
>> You were so close.
>> Have you quit? So, this is your tactic
now. You disagree and that's your move.
The truth hurts, bro.
>> You were so close.
>> I don't know if you can still hear me
cuz last time you cut me off and I got
to a good point.
>> You were so close. You were so close.
You were so close. You see the tears in
my eyes? You were so close. So close,
man. Do me this favor. Comments are
>> I love you on Twitter. You hang on to
this one every conversation, every
point, you always revert back to this
and you always disagree. You always
disagree.
>> It's huge for you guys. It's huge
trouble.
>> It's trouble for people that don't
understand.
>> Let's Let's see. You said that you're
not going to disagree with your Quran,
with what your Quran says. Would you add
to it?
>> Absolutely not. No.
>> Would you take away from what it says?
>> Of course not. Yeah.
>> Okay. Is there any part of the verse I'm
trusting your honesty. Is there any part
of the verse that says that it's only
confirming part of what they have?
>> So, is there any part of the verse that
confirms all of what they have?
>> I'm going to give you another chance to
answer my question.
come on.
>> You can't answer the question. If you
can't answer the question, then this
will be a good day and I will
>> If I answer the question,
>> can't come back.
>> I'll answer the question as long as you
let me ask you a question after that.
>> Got you. Is there any part of the verse
that says that it's only confirming part
or some or a bit or a piece of what they
have with them? Yes or no?
>> No.
>> Okay. The Quran says in the verse that
it's confirming what they have with
them. Meaning it's all of what they
have. Not some of it all in general.
>> That's your assumption. Wait. I I agreed
with your point. I agreed with your
point. So my question was so you're
you're saying um it's not part of it
etc. So I agree right so my point is how
can you use this verse to claim that the
Quran is confirming that everything that
is with them is correct. It mentions it
confirms
>> because it says it's confirming what
what is with them.
>> It says it's confirming what is with
them. That means everything they have
with them the Quran attests to its
truthfulness.
>> Okay. to say some of it or part of it.
That would be you adding to the text.
>> I agree with your point here. So your
point is the Quran is confirming.
>> So let's let's even Okay, I'm going to
do what nobody else has done. Yeah.
Let's grant you the fact that he could
be saying that everything that is with
you is correct.
>> No, that's not granted.
>> No, no,
>> don't grant it to me.
>> I disagree. I disagree. But to make my
next point, I'd have to be in agreement
>> so you can understand.
>> Well, I don't like that. I I want us to
solidify what the verse says.
>> So you're not willing to move on until
someone agrees with your point
>> until we until we solidify the point of
what the verse says cuz the moving on
when you can't even admit what the verse
says.
>> No, I do admit clearly.
>> You admit that what they have with them,
the Quran says it's true. What they
presently have in their possession,
right?
>> I agree that the Quran says what they
have with you. Yeah. It confirms what
what is with you. So I agree that what
they have in their so what they have in
their possession the Quran affirms it is
true right
>> so what what so the the verse exactly
say no no I'm going to agree but you
have to agree with the verse not your
reasoning sorry you
>> according to the verse what they have
with them
>> is true correct what they having is true
correct
>> it is confirming what is with you yeah
so I agree so I agree with the the
Quranic verse
>> Zachariah how you doing
>> hey what's up man can hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you loud and clear. You
a Muslim?
>> Yeah, of course I'm a Muslim.
>> Were you listening to that?
>> Yes, I was, man. But I got to say, you
you got to you got to be studied, man.
Because the the the fallacies that you
always, you know, present to Muslims of
like I was listening to you, the the guy
before that, and you were like, is it
either this or that? It doesn't need to
be one or the other. The the options you
gave, it could be something else. there
is another answer and the brother was
trying to give it to you but you're
frustrated that he won't fall into your
fallacy.
>> Okay. Well, I I'll do the same with you
Zechariah. Um the verse says that the
Quran is came down confirming the
scriptures that is with them. To confirm
means to attest to the truth of
something. Right.
>> Well, first do you agree? Right. Before
I answer me another question after I
just asked a question, bro.
>> No. No, no. This this has to do with it
because
>> Okay, so first answer first answer the
question and then maybe expound and
maybe ask a a related question, but
first answer what I asked. Don't ignore
it. That's rude.
>> All right, state it again so I'm not,
you know, I I answer it the way you
want. Go ahead.
>> To confirm something, the definition of
confirming something means you attest to
the truth of something, right?
>> That's not true. That's not generally
true. No. If you if you have two
spreadsheets sized aside and I tell you
you need to confirm that this worksheet
this the first worksheet is correct with
the you know by using the second one
then you need to use by by default you
need to use the second one which I told
you to
>> what does the word confirm mean? Phase
one guys phase one can't get past it
with Muslims. What does the word confirm
mean Zachariah? I don't know the actual
definition, but
>> So then how you gonna tell me that I was
wrong when I defined confirming as a
test to the truth of a thing? You said,
"No, that's not true." When you don't
even know the definition.
>> When you want to confirm something
Muslims are,
>> you're trying to see they're trying to
see if what you're saying is true or
not. And what they their reply, their
confirmation,
you see how they work. Yeah. They're
confirm
it was the mode of evasion
my answer. You know why? Because in
general
the star tactic is to evade and pretend
to be stupid so that you don't make your
point. You see it's a beauty.
>> General confirmation.
>> It's a rare breed, but it's the fastest
growing religion. It's the fastest
growing movement. started off red, but
it's it's really eliminating all.
>> It's crazy that you just focus on this
one line because you have nothing else.
When you go to the rest of the Quran,
>> hey,
>> it confirms what you have in the Bible,
right?
>> Why would I try to fix something that
ain't broke?
ain't broke? If if this one line does
this to you guys, I mean, has you guys
squirming like this intellectually and
spiritually? We believe as you guys
panic and conscious and your stupidity
is being exposed. Why would I use
something else? Why why would I not keep
on the same bullet?
>> Do you do you agree that I not agree
with anything? I need an answer to my
question. What is the definition of
confirmation when you told me my
definition was wrong but said that you
don't even know the definition? I'm
telling you in this instant is the Quran
you can say attesting to the truth but
consciously editing the parts that you
know that were that were not true
>> is that what confirm means to edit to
edit out falsehoods
>> to reaffirm it's to reaffirm
>> what does that mean
to the truth it's it's reaffirming it's
re it could reaffirm the true parts and
edit the parts that are not true
throughout the Quran which I heard you.
What does it mean to reaffirm question?
>> What does it mean to reaffirm? Cuz
you're still not giving me a definition.
>> Again, it's to attest to something, but
it doesn't have to attest to it as if,
oh, this is the truth. Listen. If you
confirm, what does it mean to something?
>> Listen. Listen. If you reaffirm a story
that I told I might have said something
wrong to you,
>> Zachariah, this isn't going to last long
if you're this.
>> Reaffirm is a is an easy English word.
It's right there.
>> So, it should be easy for you to define.
What is it? What is reaffirm? What is
how do you define re reaffirm? What does
that mean,
>> brother? You give me your definition.
I'll tell you what I agree or not. Go
ahead.
>> To verify the truthfulness. Would you
agree?
>> Yes. Okay. Sure. To verify the
truthfulness. And do you agree that when
someone confirms something, right?
Again, if there's a story about, let's
say, hey, logic, me and you, you know,
we went out last night. Can you say the
story? You might say a different story
than me, right? Because I might have a
part that I missed or I might have a
part that is not true that I don't
remember correctly. The Quran does this
throughout the Quran. It it it
intentionally tells you the stories from
the Bible just like the Bible tells you
from Moses to Jesus all these stories
and it consciously edits those stories.
So it confirms those stories and it
consciously edits the parts that are not
true. And it says it. It said do not say
three, right? Do not say trinity.
>> Pause. Pause. You're going on a rant
now. So you said something important. So
you agree that to confirm means that you
verify the truthfulness of something,
right? You verify that it's true when
you confirm something, right?
>> I know where you going with this. Yes.
Can I expound? Because you see how
>> No, not yet. I let you go on for a very
long time. I only asked this to build a
point. All right. So we finally are got
some type of common ground. When you
confirm something, you verify that that
thing is true. Okay. So now I'll quote
you the verse. Now let's see if you
could be honest. The verse says,
"Believe in what I have revealed
confirming that which is with you." What
was with the Jews and Christians?
>> Sure. The Torah and the Injil. Sure.
>> Awesome. So they had the Torah and Injil
in Muhammad's time. And the Quran says
that it confirms the Torah and Injil
that they had with them in their
possession in Muhammad's time. Right.
>> Okay. Sure.
>> All right. So when the Quran is
confirming, when it says it confirms the
Torah and Gospel in Muhammad's time,
that means that the Torah and Gospel in
Muhammad's time, the Quran has just
verified it as true. Correct?
>> It's a general confirmation. Brother,
the way you go about your questions is
just what you want is an answer that
would give you like that that would make
a person's next answer just be uh you
know basically they have no other answer
than to agree with you. There's no a
general confirmation does not mean that
a general you're just representing
fallacies so that a person
>> I got you. We're going to do two more
things. The first thing I want you to do
is I want you to define general for me.
>> This is where you're going with that.
Really?
>> I mean, you're using the word. What does
it What does in general mean?
>> It it it confirms, but it it doesn't
confirm every single thing. It just it's
it confirms stuff like stories.
>> Brother, I I I know what you what you're
you're just telling me what you believe.
Respectfully, I don't give a a crap. I
need you to define general for me. What
does that mean? Yeah, that's that's not
this is not a way to have a a debate,
man. You just you just jump to, oh, what
does this mean? Every time
>> every time you're you get
>> Go ahead. I'm sorry. I didn't mean to
cut you off.
>> Like, you know what general what general
is, brother. It's it's just it's it's
broad. It's it's it's not it's not
specific. It's it doesn't Oh, yeah.
Sure. Sure, man. That really helps. And
that's why he says go back to those who
read the scripture before you. Th you
they will confirm those stories.
>> I got you.
>> They will confirm those stories. Those
stories we we have a lot of stories.
>> I got you. I got you. It's okay. So you
couldn't define.
>> You want a question for me, right?
>> One second. One second. Zachariah,
>> can you give me one question?
>> I haven't I haven't asked you anything.
>> You don't deserve you don't deserve a
question. You're not able to define. I'm
gonna give you something. I'm gonna give
you something. And then because remember
I said we're going to do two things. The
first thing is I wanted you to define
new in general. You couldn't do it. So
now we're on the second thing. This is
your opportunity to stay on the stage.
If you can do this, you can ask me
whatever you want. I promise you. Have
my word.
>> Okay.
>> You you did this to the past couple two
people. But okay.
>> No, I didn't.
>> You do this and you
>> I'm giving you this gift.
>> Okay.
>> Sure. I won't get to ask anything, but
Okay. Go ahead.
>> It depends. It depends on your
performance. Depends on on your
performance.
>> All right. Go ahead.
>> You got to have an MVP season right now.
You got to come out and play. This is
chapter 2 verse 85 of the Quran. Okay.
I'm going to read you this verse. I'm
going to give you this verse because
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give you exactly what I say is right.
What I say, I'm going to show you that
it's in the Quran. Everything that I say
is in the Quran.
>> What you say is not in the Quran. So,
I'm going to show you that according to
the Quran, you can't believe in part of
the scripture and reject other parts.
There's no such thing as a general
confirmation in your sense of oh it only
confirms some things and not the rest
which is not what general means. When
you talk about in general means the
whole other thing by the way.
>> Sure. I mean I believe in the Quran so
that doesn't really matter to me. I
don't believe in the Quran.
>> You don't believe in the Quran. You
don't.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. I'm I'm I mean I've been showing
you guys every Muslim that I've spoken
to so far does not believe in the Quran.
You guys hate the Quran. You wish Allah
didn't say what he said. Can I can I
just clarify what your position is? Can
I just steal man your position and just
see you know
>> so so you're saying right
>> throughout the whole Bible I mean
throughout the whole Quran right Allah
says these stories from the Bible and
and and and
confirms some of them and Sam edits them
like we know he's editing them or and
then it gets to this one specific line
right where he where he basically says I
you know confirms hold Hold on. Just let
me get to my conclusion. You see, I want
you to see if you agree. If that's your
position, right?
>> No, it's not. You already started off
wrong. You already started off wrong.
>> Well, look, listen. If this oneliner
says that the the the Bible is true and
all of those all the words in the Bible
are true, the rest of the Quran is a
contradiction. Right. That's what that's
that's what your position is, right?
>> Yeah. My my position is that the Quran
claims that the Bible is true but
contradicts the Bible at the same time.
That's my position.
>> Okay. So So you're saying the whole
Quran where it's consciously editing
every verse.
>> The Quran is not consciously editing the
scripture doesn't know that these things
are in the scripture. So, so you
disagree? So, you disagree that the
Bible the Bible mentions things that the
I mean that the Quran mentions things
that the Bible has said and contradicts
it by giving another fact.
>> I I disagree that the Quran does that on
purpose. No, thinking that this is in
the scripture and is correcting what it
thinks the scripture got wrong.
>> I I what what's demonstrating is that
the Quran doesn't know what's in the
scripture. It confirms and says that all
of the scripture is true and then
unknowingly contradicts the scripture.
>> I have a I have a question for you
really quick. I want to know if
>> you already you already asked. I already
answered two of your questions. Now I'm
about to give you my verse I was about
to give you and then I want you to do
>> what you just said is not true. So
>> whatever you say let's see. So it says
chapter 2 verse 85. It says what do you
believe in part of the book and
disbelieve in part? What shall be the
recompense of those who do that except
disgrace in this life and on the day of
resurrection awaits from them the most
terrible of punishment? And Allah is not
unaware of what you do. According to the
verse, does Allah allow for people to
believe in some of the scripture and
reject other parts of the scripture?
>> Uh his word? Yes.
>> Okay. Is his word the Torah and Gospel?
>> Yes.
>> So, are you supposed to believe in all
of the Torah and Gospel, not some of it?
>> Yes. If it was the preserved. If it's
the preserved. Yes.
>> What I need you to do for me now is
this. I just showed you where Allah says
you are not allowed to pick and choose
what you believe out of the scriptures.
You're not allowed
part of the scripture and reject the
other parts. You're not allowed to do
any of this. What I want you to do for
me is give me one verse. You have 114
chapters to use. Give me one verse in
your Quran where the Quran says that it
only confirms part of the scripture. Go
ahead.
>> Well, you already know the answer to
that. But you what you're saying is
>> the answer say the the answer is like
there is of course it doesn't say that.
But it also doesn't say that it confirms
the whole thing. You what you're you see
all these fallacies again.
>> Are you allowed to believe in some of
the scripture and reject part of it?
>> Allah's word. No. So, does Allah confirm
part of his scripture and reject other
parts of his scripture?
>> No. We believe that the Quran is Allah's
word verbatim. And
>> what about the Torah? Is it verbatim?
>> The preserved the preserved Torah.
>> Is the Torah Allah's words verbatim? Yes
or no?
>> What is the book on your
>> Get off my stage and don't you dare come
back. What are you doing back, AJ? Would
you get off my stage?